Okay. Not what I'm asking. Right. So people, if you're too triggered
right now, I want you to leave. I want you to leave. If you're
too triggered,
who gets arrested when a Palestinian baby's on the strike? Who
gets arrested? Can I ask that? Hello? Is this thing on? Lots
of Palestinian babies got killed in after October 7th in that
whole operation. Hello. Doesn't seem like any of those people.
Who's arrested for that? Were people arrested for that? Well,
it seems like probably there's just no mechanism to hold these
people legally responsible, right?
Just about back to the Pisco stuff. I think I've done enough
tangents. Let's watch him cover this Assan video. I don't know
what this is going to be
>> This was their old podcast that they did together, right?
>> Turned a blind eye to to Israel not following their
commitments on. Dude, by the way,
there's a reason people really don't want to go back and watch
these conversations, and it's because when you go back and watch
these conversations and know where the Israel Palestine like
conflict went, when when it was October 7th and like within 2
3 weeks of that, you had arguments. Okay, you could have an argument.
Now two going on nearly what 2 and 1/2 years later. Now it's
tough to be on the pro Israel side to be like oh Israel at a
point the whole time. Now Han looks way better in retrospect.
Okay.
It's like way way way dead way way different. All right. >> What's
the date of this too? Let's let's get the date. Leftovers.
Why was it called leftovers? your left
self-deprecating thing. It's October
>> Not chat today. Yeah, but that's cuz he's got a bunch
of DJers in his chat, right? That's why.
That's why he would have a whole bunch of DG people in his chat.
Oh, even Ethan looks better here because he was before he became
a psycho. Well, is this so I forget the progression. Did they
go from this leftovers episode to the personal conversation on
Hassan's stream? What's the order of those two things? Because
I do think the personal conversation on Hassan's stream, I remember
watching that and being like, "Oh, Hassan was way nicer on this
stream than I remember." Like way nicer to Ethan. I still think
it was like an ego thing on both of their sides where nothing
had to turn in a fight into a fight the way it did. They just
neither of them was willing to like basically say, "Hey, time
out." That's for me personally, man, that's got to be a thing
you can do with your friends is like basically go, "Hey, this
going in a direction I don't want it to go." like time out. We
need to take a time out and find somebody to like include in
this conversation so we don't blow things up right now cuz this
this conversation that sorry that conversation totally didn't
have to turn into them like ending their friendship. It didn't
have to at all. Do all the pro-Israel people have to take back
the bad arguments now? No. I just think like basically a lot
of the pro-Israel arguments went like well I think you have this
opinion because you don't because you can't see reality and you
can't really prove it. You just suspect that this will happen,
but you have no evidence to suggest that it will happen. And
now we have a lot of evidence to suggest that it will happen.
So, so now it's like way different, right? That was it was the
standard liberal argument. You don't really have evidence for
this. You're saying something without evidence. That which is
like asserted without evidence can be dismissed without evidence.
Right? That was how they would do that. And now there's like
a whole bunch of evidence. So they might even say like, "Oh,
well, you were wrong back then cuz you didn't have the evidence."
But it's like, "Well, I had evidence. He just didn't trust the
evidence. You know, it turns into that conversation. I think
this is what >> I think I think Destiny might have said
that it's probably a genocide now. Did I did I hear that one
correctly?
Yeah. I think I think the pro-Israel side like basically had
to go, you know what? Uh, these guys went insane. If only there
were evidence that they would go insane, right, guys? Right.
>> Less than a week a after. Okay, that's the context.
>> I can maybe say the idea of actions are genocidal. Okay.
Yeah. >> Agree with what you said. Like again, it's important.
>> Was this the last episode?
1.7 million
>> For everyone to acknowledge that Hamas
the result of, you know, Israel's treatment of of of the Palestinians.
And >> yeah, this kind of happened. Yeah, this kind of
happened. There were a lot of people there's a lot of a lot of
different stuff going on this whole >> It's just You're
right. If you the And I I think it's
now here's the problem.
Is Pisco Pisco's ended his stream now or is he not edited his
stream now? Cuz I want to watch this, but I also want the chat.
Oh, never mind. We got chat over here. We're good. We're good.
We're good. I need chat. Okay, that's I if I don't have the chat
here, then what are we even doing? Okay, I need the chat.
>> Thank you.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Okay. So, is he saying that he agrees
that Hamas is the result >> requires you to treat Palestinians
with
are still the Palestinians, not uh with an endless bombing campaign
in Gaza. The only way to the only way to destroy the influence
that Hamas has is by starving it out. And I don't mean literally
by starving the entire Gaza Strip. starving Hamas and ridding
it of its influence requires you to treat Palestinians with dignity
and offer them equality and and and and follow through on the
the former promises that the international community has made.
>> Okay, he might be hiding power level here. But what
I'm hearing here is that
it I think it's implied that an objective here is to take Hamas's
power away and that the way to do that is X, Y, or Z. But I'm
again that's just out of context of the broader set of beliefs
just in context of here >> Aiden turned a blind eye to
to Israel not following their commitments on >> fully uh
agree with what you >> totally agree. Okay. So Ethan is
expressing agreement with that sentiment. The sentiment being
that the way to end Hamas.
>> Okay. How much was he how much was he overanalyzing
is to uh make
>> How much is he overanalyzing right now? Be honest. be
honest. How much is this gonna happen? He agrees. So he agrees
in SO MUCH AS NO, STOP. >> RIGHT. BY THE Palestinian people,
>> he does it the entire time. >> Deprive them of
the kind of fuel that ideological fuel perhaps or the fuel that
um only oppression might bring about. So there's an agreement
here.
>> Like again, it's important for everyone to acknowledge
that Hamas is
the result of, you know, Israel's treatment. Dude, Hassan's head
is so
This set just served to highlight it that like his
his shoulders are broader, like way broader than Ethan's and
his head is like way way smaller widthwise
>> of the Palestinians.
>> But Ethan here agrees that Hamas is um at least causally
related to
Israel's treatment of Palestinians. So there's an agreement here
>> and it's just you're right if you the and I think it's
obvious but I guess
people don't want to confront it but the obvious solution >> he
says he says it's obvious and the obvious solution >> is
to don't give them a reason to turn to terrorists. >> Okay,
[snorts]
>> you know it's pretty obvious >> but there it is.
Here's Marco Rubio. There can be no ceasefire, negotiated solutions,
or peaceful coexistence with depraved barbarians who murder teenage
girls, children, the elderly, and then dump them in the streets
of Gaza so bloodthirsty crowds can desecrate their bodies. It
must be must be eradicated and Israel must respond
in all caps to this and any future attacks from the I mean what
he's doing here is like the Hamas >> the Humus >> the
Humus murderers are 1,000% barbarians who murdered children teenage
girls which specifically he has a >> Well, I mean sure
I mean the attacks were barbaric. I hope there Oh, sorry. There
can be no ceasefire. It's low resolution.
Hamas must be eradicated and Israel must respond disproportionately.
Okay.
>> I mean >> he goes who murdered
>> all war is barbaric. No that's not true. There's like
a I mean sorry how should I put this? Yes, but that doesn't mean
we accept that like people committing war crimes. That doesn't
mean we should accept people committing war crimes.
Right. Obviously, people can do barbaric things in war. >> You
need the girls. >> I didn't mean [snorts] to say. I was
like, "No, it's it's like it's we shouldn't allow that to block
us from, you know, making certain commitments about how we engage
in warfare." >> What about teenage boys? We don't care
about them. Just like it's a weird focus, right? Any [snorts]
>> also true. Like weird odd. >> Anytime you call
out teenage girls,
>> we really care about war crimes still. Are you okay?
Yeah, we care about war crimes. Yes. Yep. That's true. I'm going
to raise an eye. [__] do you mean? Why would it matter
what president? Why would my principles change because Donald
Trump's in office? That's the most thing I've ever heard in my
life. Did that happen to you? Your principles changed cuz Donald
Trump's in office? Are you that weakwilled?
What's What are you saying in the chat? Stop telling on yourself
in the chat. >> Thanks them, you know. >> Yeah. By
the way, they >> but to finish my point, he was saying
he's he's conflating Hamas, who are bloodthirsty murderers,
to justify
>> This is right after October.
Ethan, I think credit to him,
is recognizing that the the crimes of the group of Hamas don't
necessarily extend to
root and stem the Palestinian >> disproportionately. And
again, like I don't know if they like the videos that I saw that
made me emotional before of the Palestinian dad, you know, with
with his daughter holding her like this, like she was like gray
and dead, like a eight-month old baby, like a beautiful newborn,
innocent, beautiful child.
Like, I don't I don't know if he's this this man. I don't know
if Marco Rubio uh has ever seen anything like that or if it would
change him, but I can't imagine that seeing that would not have
an impact on these ghouls to see what they're actually wishing
for. It >> it might not be impactful for Marggo Rubio,
but it certainly would be impactful for many people who are completely
uh oblivious to what's going on, which is precisely the reason
why that never gets any coverage. Uh this isn't to say that like
uh Israeli civilian casualties are are uh >> Oh, he's he's
referencing Palestinian babies being killed, right? This is Palestinian
babies.
>> No, before of the Palestinian dad, you know, with with
his daughter. >> Okay, I missed that. Yeah. So, so so he
they're criticizing
this is Ethan, right? And and maybe there's missing context from
before, but this is Ethan critic.
Assan hides his power level, dude.
>> The um overly hawkish attitude of Marco Rubio in light
of
the Palestinian baby >> holding her like this like she
was like gray and dead like a 8-month old baby like a beautiful
newborn innocent beautiful child.
Like I don't I don't know if he's this this man. I don't know
if Marco Rubio uh has ever seen anything like that or if it would
change him. But >> I think Ethan's being very reasonable
here. I can't imagine that seeing that would not have an impact
on these ghouls to see what they're actually wishing >> It
might not be impactful for Margot Rubio, but it certainly would.
>> Hey, be careful talking to mods. All
be careful talking to mods. >> He's talking to real Kathy
Doyle there.
Is that Is that Who's I know for a fact Pisco does not look at
that avatar in the stream and that makes it really funny. I know
I know he he'd be like a little
that he'd be put off there. All right. Wait, who? Wait, did I
get the wrong person? >> My bad. Wrong person.
>> Be careful. All right.
>> Be impactful for many people who are completely uh oblivious
to Cathy's >> And here's Hana Green. >> The reason
Pisco just really liked that Avatar for some reason. Pisco just
couldn't help bringing that avatar up on screen again. He just
couldn't help it. He just had to. For some reason, he had to
do it. I don't know why. >> Why that never gets any coverage.
>> That's a joke. That's a joke. That's a joke. That's
a joke. I think he I'm pretty sure he didn't see it. Uh this
is >> that is that the Palestinian suffering doesn't get
coverage >> to say that like uh Israeli civilian casualties
are are acceptable or good. It's just that uh there is >> so
so this is not to say okay hang on. This is not to say >> casualties
are never gets any coverage. Uh this isn't to say that like uh
Israeli civilian casualties are are acceptable or good. It's
just that uh there is coverage on that endlessly
>> Oh. Uh this is a kind of like unequal coverage thing.
It's not to say that they're good. >> Understandably, and
never any coverage on uh the the humanity of gazins. I've talked
about another uh aspect of this too. We in the Western world
live in the comfort of the imperial corps and and we live in
a in a comfortable >> what the [__] does that
mean? >> Security blanket. So for us, >> I know what
that means. But >> if we live in like Connecticut or Iowa
or whatever, of course we empathize significantly more with uh
Israelis that uh that were attacked by this this horde of of
scary Muslims. Like of course we empathize with that on a spiritual
level because we can't understand uh the the uh entire building
blocks being removed. It is far too alien for us to comprehend
the fear and and the reality of that kind of devastation. We
look at that and we go, "Oh, this is just like Baghdad."
What are your thoughts, JTO? What are your thoughts? Um, that
it hasn't really gone far enough yet to for me to really have
any contentions or concerns.
I think I've watched this argument happen like four times now.
I think I've seen Pisco do this argument with a thread in his
own subreddit where somebody laid out why it's stupid how people
look at this conversation.
So, it's actually a little shocking to me that Pisco's once again
doing this to be honest with you.
But, it is interesting. I enjoy, you know, I I do think that
there's um listen, you might not agree with some of the assessment
here, but there is something about like the nature of bombing
a person who like went up
and just like slit the throat of someone and and we have that
visceral kind of example of someone like up close and dirty doing
whatever. Then the
military jobber who dropped like
hundreds of payloads over the course of a conflict which causes
uh death and suffering from like but like removed almost and
I I kind of get that that's what he's I'm
>> uh you're missing a bit of context before that before
this he said he wants to see the most egregious accusation against
Assan and he picked the baby settler point.
baby settler point is
I don't think Assan agrees with like oh babies are blameless
because they're part of settler families. He was doing a semantic
argument because he didn't want to be like wrong in the moment.
He was just doing a semantic argument that sometimes like I don't
know egotistical streamers make where he's like technically there
are baby settlers and it's like I don't think he's truly trying
to argue that those baby settlers are deserving of death. Right?
That's like the argument from other people is he was just trying
to say like, "Oh, no, you should kill those babies,
right?" He's pointing out the flaw in Ethan's law logic. Okay.
Either way, it's like I I don't think he was trying to argue
that like you should go kill babies.
I I just didn't remember it being like that at all. >> He's
suggesting is that there's like a both because they're scary
Muslims and I think that that's that's true. Israeli society
more western aligned, more um understandable
I think to
the cultural sensibilities of Americans
um especially like coastal people um who
where there's large communities where they're very familiar with
um uh such populations although they're big Muslim communities
too in fairness. So >> um he justified settlers then said
babies are settlers, right? Uh is it that simple? because I I
don't believe I don't believe it's said with like that kind of
intention. We can we can definitely watch it again. I think I
have a feeling we're gonna watch it again. This apparently them
they're working their way up to the baby seller point, right?
But even putting that aside, just the the bombing
deaths in both the numbers and the way they're being, they just
don't strike at the heart the way
it's like small arms
uh you know, up close and personal
shooting
precisely
the um the grandmas at the bus station. And so I don't even disagree
with this point here,
which is an enemy that deserved it in the minds of Americans.
So uh that is >> and then of course the lineage of 9/11
and um our conflict in the Middle East for the last you know
40 years or so
since um you know the Gulf War and maybe
>> also another reason why uh Americans
>> uh possibly if they talk about the journalist I think
I remember him wearing that hat I feel like when he did the crying
about the journalist. One sec, I'll be right back. >> In
support of, you know, uh, the the Israeli occupation. >> Here's
Ben Shapiro. I mean, no surprise
>> I don't think that anything incredibly stupid was said
there. And but okay, here's Ben Shapiro, >> obviously.
But still, >> he's been banging for blood non-stop. >> I
mean, here's a video of the human. >> He's been what for
blood? Is this uh bane? Bane is a deep, loud, and prolonged vocalization,
a mix of arc and howl, primarily produced by scent hounds to
signal they have scented or cornered
Is this uh what is this? There's some sort of Let me look up
Bane.
What' you say? Discrimination. Is there any history of the term
Bane
with um
some kind of bigotry?
Oh, he doesn't get it. YOU BANG PIG. You bang pig dog. I remember
the clip. Does Does Pisco not know the clip? >> I'm not
sure. person by themselves to me. Don't >> listen, I've
logged enough Hassan to know you baing PIG. YOU FILTHY BAING
PIG DOG. I I remember it. I know it.
>> Is there anything like specific on like the Judaism
front?
Anti-semitism because like I called those DHS schools the other
day rats and um who is this on saying that about? Um I think
I'm pretty sure. I think it was Republicans at that point.
Hold on. Can I I'll I'll see if I can find it.
>> So I just like the animal compar there's a lot unfortunately
and I don't think I'm trying to look for like antiseism.
He said Bane. Bane for blood is an expression. Okay. Okay. So
we don't have a problem with Bane by itself, right? Bane. Unless
someone can can produce
something other that there's like a specific connotation of Bane.
Um I'm just going to assume that that's like I don't use it.
I can't find it. I can't find the you bang pig dog again. Oh,
it was cops. It was definitely a cop killed somebody and and
almost certainly Hassan was freaking out about the cops killing
But yeah, I I'm pretty sure that's the the context he used it
in. I think that's that's the weird thing is he always does it
with reference to like fascist. He he calls people fascists with
that word, right?
So he calls people hogs, he calls them pigs, pig dogs.
That's like his word for fascist. and he overlaps that with Israel.
And then people say when he says it about Israelis or sorry Zionists
even then people and he totally conflates Zionism and fascism
like the Israeli government and fascism.
Yeah, it's uh
it's pretty obvious he's like doing the fascist thing again.
>> Yeah, but >> if there is Yeah. and special uh
reporter for human rights in Palestine. We are horrified of what's
happening and we are calling for a truce and here's a video of
you know Gaza being bombed by missiles and then Ben >> Oh
sure he said bang for blood I'm just saying that's the context
he uses it in that could be perceived as anti-semitic probably
why somebody would have said it was anti-semitic in here because
they would have tied it to that if somebody did say that like
banging owes anti-semitic if somebody or were asserting that
I would say it would be based on you being paid dog >> and
his infinite empathy The end >> was Pisco also confused
as to what I imperial core meant. Yeah, I think most people don't
think of honestly when I hear Imperial Core I think of like Star
Wars or
or like Attack on Titan or not maybe not Attack on Titan. I think
of like anime.
But I get the idea. You're in some empire, right?
And you have like the safe home worlds that get all the food
and all the money and all the riches and they're like super happy.
You have where the imperial expansion happens where they're like
taking all the money from other people, taking all the resources
from other people. >> Human nature. >> So criticizing
Ben for not sufficiently considering the lives of Palestinians.
Okay. Ethan again reasonable. >> Told them that they can
right off
>> and like this is such all these people but looking at
Ben, I mean it's such a lack of human empathy. It it's >> It's
like it's just evil, man. But there it is. That's >> What
color is Pisco's screen that he's fading into the background?
>> Benny Boy. And um >> so far, this is making me
very sympathetic to Ethan. >> One more. Again, no no surprises
here, but Charlie Kirk, they these people betray principles of
Judaism and and and centuries of history of always siding with
those who have been oppressed, always being at the forefront
of social justice and and fighting for
So, here's Hassan uh speaking positively about the history of
support for oppressed groups, which in the American context is
like is true, right? I mean, like this guy used to be a big fan
of my stream. I recognize this name. Tanky scum. This guy would
not have been This is one of the guys I almost certainly lost
during the Assan is bad arc.
Almost
Almost certainly.
lawyers were at the forefront of a lot of civil rights movements.
>> Um, and so yeah, like >> uh I've seen him make
a couple of these arguments in Pisco chat recently. It's very
funny. >> This is
I think >> Well, thank you. I will find you. >> I
will find you. >> The historical
pedigree
of fights for freedom. And um again, you can disagree with it
in the context of Israel Palestine, but um no, I think that that's
again showing
a distinction between what he takes to be the oppressive regime
of Zionism and um his notion of
uh values or whatever >> for all people. It's it's really
really really disgusting to see that 100%.
>> I didn't want to read this one. So um basically uh showing
all these goals feeling very comfortable. >> It's not positively.
It's being used to put down the threats Israelis face. It's not
a good faith anal analysis of history in that you think it's
inaccurate. It's an accurate description that people have not
been on the forefront of
>> protecting minorities and the oppressed >> That's
what I want to answer to first and then we can get into the Israeli
part. But like do you think it's in do you think anything he
said there was inaccurate? First off, Zachary Cohen 89.
>> Can you identify an inaccurate statement there from
what we just heard?
No, it's accurate, but it's being used to juxtapose the history
of Israeli. I think it's being just juxtaposed
with respect to the he has a view on what Israel is doing here,
but I I don't want to
I don't want to conflate the substantive issue of what the Israeli
conflict is and to double count it, right? So, here's the problem,
right? If he's bastardizing
history, that's one thing, right? That that's its own phaua or
whatever. I don't want to double count
to the extent that you believe he's wrong on Israel Palestine.
I don't want to double count that and be like, "Oh, he's using
this for this end." Well, if you already disagree with him on
that, it doesn't sound like the use of history, which is accurate
or a narrative that you think is already false. I don't want
to like double whammy him. I hope that makes sense. just like
be be aware of that that the disagreement on substantive
policy grounds should not be used I think to rear its head
um in other places except for where there's like an additional
bias an additional indication that faith like that thing done
um and then someone
principles of Judaism >> surprises here by Charlie Kirk
they these people betray >> these people I mean he's not
saying uh it sounds like he's just like
him bringing up Charlie Kirk. So it doesn't sound like it's um
because they just responded to, you know, these people are betraying
the values. I don't think there's anything wrong with that.
Just being honest. >> Principles of Judaism and and and
membership history of always siding with those who have been
oppressed, always being at the forefront of social justice and
and fighting for emancipation for all people. Uh it's it's really
really disgusting to see that.
>> I didn't want to read this one. So um basically uh showing
all these ghouls feeling very comfortable with >> calling
them cool back expressing their desire for genocide >> and
again I I do think and again thank you for the memberships. I
do think that Ethan is being very reasonable here in light of
>> bro they got to find something to do with um what is
it Streamlabs when you get YouTube memberships and it reads off
each one individually.
Some someone got to fix that. Something got to be done about
that. That's like totally unmanageable man. You can gift like
50 subs. People get 50 subs sometimes on YouTube and it just
reads one reads them all off one at a time.
This is a Leninist though, so ideologically he is an authoritarian
left he's an authoritarian leftist that supports violence to
take over
Sure. But like
how do I explain it? Like
is there any evidence that he wants to use violence to take over
now?
Like like I I think you could say I ideologically like appreciate
this, support it. In my ideal world, this is what I'd support.
But like within the current political dynamic, I couldn't possibly
truly subscribe to all of these values. And so I don't it's like
in a world where I was facing the same circumstances, that's
how I would respond. But is there like like the people in Russia,
the reason Leninism came up came about and there was a violent
revolution like that has that's way different circumstances than
what you live in in the United States, right?
Do you think Assan's incapable of grappling with that at all?
The fact that like there's just no way that you could really
justify doing the same kinds of violence to gain power. Like
I I think most people are capable of of
understanding that they're in totally different circumstances
now. No, like you said, he doesn't have the stomach for it. Yeah.
Well, sorry, but I'm saying I assume that he would look at the
current circumstances, see like the material conditions most
people are in and go, "Oh, like violence is not required here.
violence isn't something I could, you know, in good conscience
argue for here in the same way.
I I assume that, but >> a very like circumstances that
are super traumatizing even for people who are not in Israel,
you know, I I knew uh I have friends who are who
they was it's not like this was a
uh humble brag. What the
>> a far away thing that they felt, right? very much felt
personal
even in America. And so, um, credit to Ethan here, I think, big
credit. >> Western media. Oh, here is an, uh, an Israeli,
uh, hold on. Who said this? Okay, so here it is in in Hebrew.
This was from an unnamed defense official told Israel's channel
13 that the Palestinian territory, home to more 2 million residents,
would be reduced to rubble. Quote, Gaza will eventually turn
into a city of tents. There will be no buildings. The ground
maneuver will surprise Hamas. The official said in a start warning
to a terrorist group behind the weekend assault that killed more
than 1,200 Israelis. >> I mean, the Israeli defense minister
literally said, "We're shutting off the electricity. We're shutting
off the food supply and we're shutting off the water into Gaza
because we are not we're fighting human animals." Or a better
translation, I think, was beasts. >> Like, but ultimately
though, that's collective punishment. It is a violation of the
Geneva suggestions. I don't want to call it conventions. Uh
>> is that like some >> It is. This has happened
for far too long. You can't attack the press. You can't attack
uh
>> like a couple hours later. >> Don't trust me.
>> Okay. So, >> direct directly just a violation.
>> At this time, I want to turn my attention to some of
the very evil takes I've heard
uh some prominent folks making about Israelis. Here is one. >> Okay.
So we have some throat clearers
and going through bad takes and so
the question here is is Hassan
is he going to provide cover for these bad takes. >> Such
example of a dude and this guy is very popular. He has 1.6 million
>> Oh this here's the second thought moment. Here's the
second thought
>> Very popular. >> I think we should be clear here.
He just called infants militants.
Sorry. I just remember I dude this some of this stuff's like
seared into my >> YouTuber called Second Thought. Sorry,
this picture. >> Oh yeah, he's my friend. >> This
is my friend. >> I like I like JT. >> What's going
on in occupied Palestine is unprecedented. No doubt we'll have
wall to- wall coverage of atrocities now that it's the genocidal
settlers
on the receiving end. Well, I'd like to think none of us would
have been none of us would have done well in the Japanese Imperial
Army. Okay, that's what I'd like to think. that none of us could
ever dehumanize another group so badly that we'd ever just think,
you know what, the those babies, throw them in a pot, boil them,
boil them, cook them, put them in a stew,
boil them, mash them, put them in a ste Yeah, that's the
Don't do that to babies. Okay. Don't do that to babies. I mean,
that's just a
>> very wrong
>> take on the October 7th massacre, which occurred not
on any settlement, unless he's considering all of Israel to be
a settlement or something. This is what a liberation struggle
looks like. Solidarity and victory to the Palestinian people.
So, I would express this as expressing support for mod. >> Kathy's
gone from asking for Ma to just saying, "Hi, Pisco. I would love
to
love to have you on the show. I How does he do it? >> And
expressing support for October 7th. That's how I interpret it
in that he
>> Isn't that from The Hobbit? It is. But the Japanese
Imperial Army at um Nang King put babies in pots of boiling
Just dropped them. Boop. Made big stew pots of boiling water.
Dropped the babies in. Maybe even boiling oil. I forget. Boop.
Baby in. Very not cool. >> Ports of liberation. That's
implied. Uh, they also would throw babies in the air and see
if they could like, you know how you know how in every anime
there's like the EIS the um the like slashes from your from your
scabbard?
You know how like they they as they're pulling as they're drawing
their sword, they like do a slash? They did that with babies
in N King. They'd like throw the baby in the air and they try
to take their sword and do the like the the drawing slash and
see if they could cut the baby in half.
Pretty crazy, man. And then someone responds, "The attacks on
Israeli civilians were awful, but attacks on Palestinian civilians
have been going on for years with little comment in the west
and will continue until there's a proper solution and not a militarized
apartheite Zionist state in power." This I view as a more you
don't have to um agree with like the what aboutism, especially
in the time, but I view that as not um inherently supporting
the attacks in um October 7th, which I do view the first tweet
to be. Imagine someone comes to your town, murders your neighbors,
kicks you out of your home your family has lived in for generations,
and re relocates you to an open air prison. Are those occupiers
civilians? No, they're criminals and accompllices in genocide.
Yeah, I'm sorry. I don't I don't believe that the the collective
punishments I'm just not >> Um, he said, "What's going
on in occupied Palestine is unprecedented. No doubt we'll have
it on." Wait, hold on. I I don't have my glasses today. >> It's
just the
>> Oh, no. I can't read. I can't see it. I pretend I do
not see. able to see it. I just got to click on it so I can read
it. But go ahead. You can read it out loud. You can read it out
loud >> here. You know what? Let me show you this. Is it
on the Google doc? >> Let me show you the video first.
You This will be easier for you. He basically says the same thing
here. >> So, here he is doing a >> I actually think
you should stick to the the text first cuz that's
>> that's a that's a wild comment, dude.
>> I think is this program? I've been on the podcast. >> I
don't know what it's called, but this is just a clip from Yes.
So, here so here's his take on this. Uhoh.
Is did the Palestinians actually take civilian hostage or is
that fake news? Um, I don't care. The occupages
>> First of all, just straight off the bat, >> the
person that's targeting is Hakim. He is a a doctor in Iraq. Uh
and and of course just to put this into a a a decent frame of
reference for those >> a decent frame of reference >> uh
who are unfamiliar, I think he will probably have a much more
ruthless position on the matter considering uh how he feels about
American forces and what they've done to his >> Yeah. But
I mean here we're we're removing Hassan, right? Removing his
this is now becoming and I and I view this by the way honestly
>> justifying murder. Um, no. I think I think the way they
defend this, I will find you. The way they defend this is is
they would say, "Okay, there's like a family who is captured
like a civilian family of
they're captured like this, not the not any military members,
just just women and children captured by some dried into a ghetto
and held hostage for like better conditions in some way. Is that
a horrible thing?
Is that a thing where you have to feel sympathy for the
Right? I think that's the way they'd argue that. I don't know
if you agree with that. You might totally disagree with that,
but that's how they would argue it is that that's how they see
it.
I don't think like if you truly believe that to find better I
mean do you feel sympathy for the the
like literally the reason the have to have to take those hostages
to try to get better conditions is because of the civilians like
co-signing this thing that's happening right why I'm not saying
it's my view I'm saying that's their view and it really comes
down to how bad you think the Palestinian conditions are how
acute the problem is how much like how quickly it's progressing
and getting worse Right? Like a lot of it is
is basically all in that argument. And if you can agree with
how bad the genocide in Palestine is, you can agree that it's
like a genocide and some other stuff, then you probably should
agree with some of the things Hassan's saying.
I think it's the weird thing about Ethan is he says he believes
it's a genocide, but then he doesn't believe like certain steps
taken to end that genocide or stall that genocide are valid.
And it's like probably if you thought it was a genocide, really
and truly, you wouldn't think the same thing, right?
You'd probably have a little more understanding for some of even
the most extreme arguments on that side.
Kind of leading to a question of do you really believe it's a
genocide or you saying that so people stop talking [__]
Sometimes pro-Israel people do this kind of thing where what's
Israel supposed to do? Why would Israel want to do that? Right?
And I see the same exact kind of thing here, which is like
now it's even just personal. >> But like I don't I don't
necessarily disagree or I don't necessarily agree with that.
I actually probably lean on the side of Yeah. depending on what
that family knows. The the actual, you know, humans there, the
the civilians, like they might be somewhat blameless in this
whole thing, right? They're not necessarily like totally evil.
Go to 58 seconds. Okay. Wait.
>> Why to an individual? Well, given his view, it makes
sense that XYZ, but unlike
the kind of normative takes that he was giving regarding these
other people and and maybe this is important context or something,
but like what? Oh, yeah. Given his take on American intervention,
of course, he would be more um ruthless or something, but okay,
thanks for the obvious um position on the matter considering
uh how he feels about American forces and what they've done to
his >> This I'm pretty sure is all second >> No,
the one who said >> No, I know. I know. I know. But here
sent your question much. Did the Palestinian actually take civilian
hostage or is that fake news? >> So wait, who's talking
there? >> That's Hakim. >> Okay. So second thought
is the one who says I don't care and laughs. >> Wait, you
say it? >> Um I don't care.
>> The guy with the accent. >> Yeah, that's Hakim.
Second thought is an >> So Second Thought is the guy who's
asking the question. >> No, Hakim is the one who read the
same. It's the same guy this whole time >> from chat is
a super chat. >> Did the Palestinians actually take civilian
hostage or is that fake news? Um I don't care. >> Anyway,
he agrees with him. So let's just [__] the occupiers
not civilians. that that is what >> the occupiers are not
civilians. I mean that's just like false right? I mean like occupiers
you can be an occupier and a civilian.
I think it just is um
understand the the term right now. Maybe you say that attacks
against civilians are justified. That's just uh
United States and they they said you know what Cincinnati, Ohio
is our ancestral home. And you know, everyone knows that's blatantly
false, but they they take your home, >> they murder your
grandma, they bulldoze like your neighbor's house. Are those
people civilians there? No, they're occupiers. And those those
are criminals. That that is there are no civilians there. And
>> there are no civilians. Hang on.
inside 67, right? >> They take your home, they murder your
grandma, they bulldoze like your neighbor's house. Are those
people civilians there? No, they're occupiers. And those those
are criminals. that that is there are no civilians there and
>> so according to second thought >> Mhm. He says
that every Israeli is an occupier and there are no citizens there
in respon >> that's how I understand it >> responds
to the two there are two different schools of thought here so
the first is >> and the take in the comments is bas
>> the yeah of course the 1948ers
>> I I think that uh he's responding
to
the base things I don't think he's saying bass there Do we think
he's saying based >> first is >> and the take in
the comments is based >> the Yeah, of course the >> of
course is is he like yeah of course they would think that. I
don't necessarily interpret that as him saying it's based.
uh believe >> they believe all of it is uh
>> There's two different schools of thought within I would
say anti-Zionism.
Uh those who believe that all matter of of settlements that were
propped up even in the inception. So I think so far people might
be getting the wrong weaselness right I think the weaselness
here is removing his normative view so far right maybe there's
more but so far he has given he's giving these kind of descriptive
claims and analyzing like different schools of thought
but but so far I haven't like identified something incorrect
he said
but there's definitely weaselness and I think the weaselness
is um so far right and there might be more refusing to comment
normatively on it after commenting you know quite openly about
like Shapiro these other people right >> of the Israeli
nation state uh are are unjustifiable and that they are settlers
that so they extend beyond your perspective that you agree with
which is West Bank is uh a a settler occupation
>> I think it's an an extremely evil thing to say what
>> okay so now Ethan is uh pressing the issue and he's
asking for a normative assessment from Hassan. I think this is
an evil thing to say and I agree that it is an evil thing to
say. >> He said, >> let me ask you this. >> No,
no. What do you think? What he said >> all right. Weasel
>> is evil. >> I I think it is one unproductive and
two >> unproductive isn't what you were asked. So this
is a dodge. This is like when you say uh should you have endorsed
>> No, no, hold on. It's an optics thing, right? That's
what it is.
It's like, do you think
do you think um oh do you think you know Donald Trump should
be Well, it's really bad optics to say that like well that's
obviously not an answer to the question,
>> That would be that that's what I feel like that answer
is here. That's an unproductive conversation to have. >> Kamla
didn't like >> No, you should probably you're you probably
should be saying no if that's what you think. Um,
Kamala didn't uh
deserve my vote or something, right? It's it's the same kind
of dodge only here he's pressing you and you're just like you're
just >> Let me ask you this. >> No, no. What do you
think what he said is evil? >> I I think it is one unproductive
and two >> one two and two >> uh it does not meet
the realities on the ground and it's not >> oh that's weasel
>> not a a viable solution. >> It is not a viable
solution. See if he had said and it's not a viable solution therefore
it's evil. I would be like, "Okay, he he answered it in a kind
of
whatever tone, but this is a pure dodge. It's a pure dodge. 100%
pure." I think he gets less into dodging, right? There's probably
like other considerations here that I don't I don't think you
necessarily give Hassan charity on them, but there's other things
he's considering. He's probably considering that when he does
when he says this, how those guys are going to receive the clip
as well.
So, he probably doesn't want to just immediately sell his friends
down the river, right? He probably wants to be nuance. He probably
wants to like try to understand like try to not make them out
to just be evil.
Um, that's almost certainly clouding his answer a little bit.
Like you don't have to give him additional uh what do you call
consideration for this. Okay.
You don't I'm trying to think of like how how would we put it?
Yeah, there's like there's something going on here where he doesn't
quite want to like sell them down the river immediately, but
there's probably something there too where he does think that,
you know, the way the average civilian acts in a West Bank settlement
is not very civilian-like.
And probably saying that these people are civilians who don't
deserve anything, like who deserve blanket protection as civilians
might be inaccurate.
You know what I'm saying? that like if you're going to be out
in one of the new West Bank settlements right now, they aren't
talking about the West Bank. I thought they were saying, "Oh,
occupiers, right?" Sorry, I thought it was settlers because we
eventually get to settler babies. That's my bad. It eventually
gets to settlers. So, I up uh thanks for being here, Zanak. See
you. >> So, saying so calling, just to be clear, calling
babies. >> No, of course not.
>> Of course not. >> Of course, of course. They're
not babies. So, I just want to say
>> but he's not saying it's good to kill >> I just
want to say this guy's a evil piece of for saying that. >> Can
we can we can I uh can I ask you a >> Can I let me finish?
>> Okay. So, how he responded to baby thing so far makes
me think he's not justifying the of babies. >> Okay, we'll
finish this. But, but I do have a question for you because I
think you're going to agree with something I'm about to say.
>> Yes, let's just finish it and then we'll >> Invaded
the United States. And they they said, "You know what? Cincinnati,
Ohio is our ancestral home." And you know, everyone knows that's
blatantly false, but they they take your home, they murder your
grandma, they bulldoze like your neighbor's house. Are those
people civilians there? No, they're occupiers. And those those
are criminals. That that is there are no civilians there in the
illegal military occupation.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So that's number one. >> I mean, that's
so callous. It's kind of hard to even believe just how flippant
he can be about calling babies militants that that are deserving
to be.
>> Very beautifully put. Number two, uh much more important.
Now give us credit to be killed.
>> Hassan is nodding. Why is Hassan nodding here? I'm seeing
nodding >> very close to much more important. >> Is
he nodding with Ethan? I think he's nodding with >> Ethan.
Um the track record of Palestinians has been
>> Did this happen? Did people were people like uhoh, we
need to go fix this right now in chat?
We don't we don't need we need to get into chat.
Is that We'll see. I do think you could criticize Hassan here
for not directly saying like
and but Hassan does this with everything because he's just got
he's got this weird way of looking at things where he's like
if the primary issue is the Israeli occupation I'm not going
to spend he's like he looks at it like um Pisco and Josiah look
at Trump right where it's like the biggest problem is Trump I'm
not going to spend any time going after Hassan I'm going to go
after those people even acknowledging wrongdoing on that side
would be a waste of time for me Pisco doesn't look at like that.
I don't know about you side, but Pisco does sometimes
though. Pisco, sorry. Pisco is different. Pisco does think you
acknowledge your own mistakes. You try to say where they're wrong,
like your side's mistakes. Anyway, but I think Hassan basically
doesn't. That's why Hassan will say, "No, no, no, no. I don't
think it was bad that they kidnapped those civilians." That's
why he'll say like that in the middle of debates, even though
he almost certainly doesn't think it. He thinks like in the context
of Israel Palestine, you have to constantly just be focused on
Israel being evil, right? because that's the biggest issue right
now is like not even not even evil, but like their goals, their
motives, why they're doing what they're doing. You constantly
reframe to that. So, he'll have a harder time even disavowing
like Hamas in a lot of cases.
And it's like I don't I don't know if that's even really indicative
of his opinion in a vacuum. It's like he literally just won't
do it to certain people, which is kind of weird.
Yeah, he ends up looking really stupid when he does this in some
cases. I don't know if this is one of those cases yet, but it's
like one of his things he does. And then I think literally if
he's talking about it with like a lefty person, he could be walked
back from that pretty easily. >> I think
>> thousands of times better than that of the Israeli occupation,
despite the fact Isra occupation does not need to brutalize.
They already have all the power. Um but they still choose to
do far far far worse. Um the worst that will happen to a person
in the Palestinian custody is that they're going to be uh um
like auctioned off for a prisoner swap, which is the historic
track record also. Um And of course >> he's not wrong about
this. This is the the original goal for the >> again here
the whis the weaselness is um in terms of the goal here uh sorry
in terms of the frame of analysis the frame of analysis is descriptive
it's not normative that's the dodge it's the same problem this
entire time is unwillingness to address the issue and to just
get into this like yeah that is what they do yes this is the
>> yeah I put this out Missy >> at the time when
Desi did the Charlie Kirk thing I was like he's lost all all
ground he had to I said this immediately oh he just forfeited
all moral ground he had to stand on with regards to Hassan. Cuz
that's exactly why Hassan won't disavow things cuz he sees it
the same way. Actually, there's a way bigger problem here. And
if people won't disavow that problem, then I won't disavow like
my problematic side or anything either. And it's like, well,
that's probably not how you should look at it. You could probably
just say bad things are bad. Pretty easy.
>> But it is historical pattern has been as opposed to
give a normative take >> military uh the the the excursion
at least if you believe that. I'm not exactly having >> okay
so interruption and and I understand the frustration here actually
because he's just dodging the normative issue and so I would
be frustrated as well. So, I don't think I think that Ethan is
perfectly justified to feel frustrated, especially because they
were both and and Ethan was willing to
I think to his credit in the aftermath days after October 7th
give um totally seen and
um throat clearing condemning of Marco Rubio and of Charlie Kirk
and all this and so I would also be frustrated. a ton of faith
in the dudes that decapitated babies to treating their PS really
well. >> I think that's kind of a psychotic take, too,
where it's like you're like it's like why are you trying to give
Hamas the benefit of the doubt on this one, you know, being like,
"Oh, they treat their prisoners awesome."
>> Well, just to be clear, Hassan didn't just say that.
Hassan just said like in general,
and that also isn't what was being said in the clip. Now, I understand
the frustration for sure, but it's not that they'll treat him
very well. It's not that we should trust them. It's that that
is what has happened in the past and that's what Susan said.
So, um again I not to
excuse the normative evilness of the clip and the weaselness
to not to engage but um I don't think that that's um what's being
said is to trust trust. It just uh kind of historical look. >> I
bet Pisco really hated Ethan. Why? I don't think so. >> Let's
let's let's not let's just, you know, let's not try to do that.
>> Okay. But anyway, and that combined with just the callous,
the laughter,
did the Palestinian actually take civilian hostage or is that
fake news? Um, I don't care
and they're laughing. >> So, let me ask you, let me pose
a question for you. >> Go ahead. >> So, you have
said that uh those in the West Bank are fundamentalists at >> I
mean, pull up the law piece. Oh, Google is free. >> Is
the claim that the uh this is untrue?
Not against civilians,
obviously. Well, he just mentioned the IDF, right? Or what did
he say? Oh, no. He's mentioning the settlers. Okay.
So, he's not allowed to bring up. Uh, it's a war crime.
What? So, it would be a war crime. Let's just make sure we understand
this. It would be a war crime for
to violently kick out
with threat of force
settlers
and to re reclaim their homes. I'm just trying to think like
like is this I'm trying to understand the claim.
is the claim that it's legal under international law.
Use force to take the homes back. Ah, >> well, let's just
get some citations, right? So, what's what's the international
law that um the claim itself is dodge? No, I agree. The whole
thing is a dodge cuz right now the claim is not about like law,
not about
>> Okay. Okay. >> And he he even um speed up a little
bit. >> He even starts by saying this sounds crazy, but
this is the legal justification of international law. I do think
it's it's not addressing an ethical issue, which um I'm just
telling you right now, if that continues, I will say that how
this clip has been represented to me is a complete misleading
piece like thing. If if this style of dodge and measel, which
I think is horrible and bad, and he should just own one of the
positions, but if it's a case, dude.
Oh, yes.
He's understanding. Okay. He's like, "Even in the worst case
scenario where Hassan continues to do exactly this,
you guys have totally lied to me about how this clip actually
sounds or what it actually means. You've totally lied."
Huge pisco victory again.
>> And people say um Hassan justified babies by which they're
playing on the ethical that he's a monster because he wants babies
dead. Then I'm going to be angry with people who made those claims
and represented this as that. This is bad for other reasons.
Okay? But it's not because of that, right? because how it's been
presented to me to be clear is Hassan wants settler babies to
be but the question here >> there's a reason why he's dodging
>> about what what the law allows for
and the previous context here makes it clear I think he's dodging
he says that I don't think it's viable I don't so he's dodging
ethical question he's not answering not addressing so um right
the hey regulations the confiscation of private property the
fourth gen convention prevents the destruction of private or
state property all right so let's see the fourth gen convention
actually let me just watch before we get into okay so because
it's not really relevant right okay this is why it's not relevant
grant has been saying the law That's not really what we're looking
at this clip for. We're looking at this clip for Is it the case
that Hassan wants dead settler babies? Thinks it's good that
settler babies get killed or something, right?
That's the question. This is a
settler babies didn't choose to be there. The is bad. That's
as barbaric as Israel saying we can't help but Palestinians because
Hamas uses them as shields. Yeah, I think so. This is a matter
of law and maybe possibly very violent, but this is a matter
of law and maybe even if you agree with this, a matter of morality,
>> if you agree with this as a matter of >> uh, have
the the hang that says >> technically the reason why the
IDF has to exist in the West Bank and behave in the oppressive
manner that they behave is because Palestinians, and this is
going to sound very radical and possibly very violent, but this
is a matter of law and maybe even if you agree with this, a matter
of morality. If you agree with so if you agree with his action
a matter of morality this was a matter of law and if you agree
with it meaning the action a matter of morality I don't think
Assan here is saying is if you agree that this is what the law
is therefore it's good I don't Pisco is being bad faith this
isn't the right clip there's a clip where Hassan says yes settler
babies are a thing yeah that's the clip this is the clip is it
bad faith to go and get more
context
is this is this really bad faith what
>> I don't see that could be bad Oh,
>> hold on. When is this? This is
four or five days ago. I don't know if this is the right clip,
but we'll see. We'll see. We'll see. >> I don't think that's
what it said there. I'm just being honest in terms of what I'm
hearing.
>> Palestinians
uh have the the legal legal >> This is the funny thing
as well, Missy, is like people literally need
a certain voice in their head to maintain these opinions. It's
very, very, very funny.
a lot of the time. Okay,
this is very funny. They they need to be hearing how how bad
this is. And you need to like pause here and basically explain
how Hassan's a liar for like 40 minutes. You 40 minutes of exposition
and clips on how Hassan hides his power level right around here
or else you can't possibly maintain the current opinion you have
on this clip. It's very funny. Okay,
>> does anybody have that? Can we get 40 minutes of just
somebody explaining how son lies all the time? on to violently
seize back their own homes from the settlers. This is a reality
and that is precisely the reason why they have to exist under
endless occupation in the >> And that's why I say if it
was settlers that would be a lot more understandable, but let's
not obuscate. Okay, I understand what you're saying. But this
>> let's not obuscate. This dude just said babies are militants.
Okay, >> just call babies militants. >> No, I I understand.
And there are baby settlers as well. There are baby settlers
as well. There are babies in the settlements. >> But the
babies that killed, they were >> I know. >> Okay,
so let's now we establish that. No, hold on. Now that we establish
that, the the other school of thought here is that all matter
of of Israelis living on uh Israel. >> Was that it? Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Is that all? Is that all? Is that all? >> Robert are a
a uh that they're also doing the ex. >> So far, he's not
saying that it's good that babies get that he wants babies to
be none of that even close. >> Same thing in the eyes of
some I I do not agree with that because I don't think that >> Yeah.
Yeah. Hang on. the exact same thing in R8. >> This is where
this is what Pisgo wants. This is where he's saying some people
say that people outside of those occupied areas, the like illegally
occupied areas would also be under the same logic targets. And
he says I don't agree with that at all. >> Uh they're also
doing the exact same thing in the eyes of some. I I do not agree
with that because I don't think that that is a a reasonable solution.
It's not fair. He doesn't believe the >> anyway
will will lead to the complete evvisceration of Palestinians
and >> and he doesn't want the complete evvisceration of
Palestinians
>> hence hence he doesn't want uh baby settlers speaking
>> I think that's a different point >> to continuously
radicalize uh uh just regular Israeli citizens in their endless
bombing campaigns and ethnic cleansing campaigns and the brutal
occupation. This is uh why many thinkers, I believe, even including
Norm Finkelestein, who has dedicated his entire life to speaking
the truth about >> Wait a second. Wait a second. Baby settlers.
Hang on a second. All right. Couple things. First off,
as a matter of fact, right, unless there's some special technical
meaning of settler, does anyone here deny does anyone here deny
does anyone here deny that babies can be settlers?
What it is to be a settler is to be part of a group that settles
in a place. Am I wrong about that? Who here disagrees with that?
Does anyone disagree that there is such a concept as >> So
I mean it's just all in the implication.
So this part isn't really meaningful. Everybody agrees with that.
The people are saying that there's there's an implication because
he just said it was legal for military action to be taken against
settlers. He is saying that like obviously since that's true,
people are saying since he said that and then he said, "Well,
no, hold on. There are baby settlers too." that Hassan is not
only saying that it would be okay or legal to attack, you know,
settler families, including the babies, but that it would be
morally justified to do so, but he's clearly dodging the moral
question and only talking about legality, right?
And so Pisco infers not that he wants babies killed, but that
he is dodging the morality in all cases because he dodged the
morality before. You can't infer a an intent here for saying
babies are settlers, too.
>> right? And on what grounds do you disagree with that?
Settler implies an
>> I don't think so. No, I don't think so. Or if you if
you said it implied intentionality, then I don't think anybody
could apply it to babies.
Right. If you said that like,
you know,
I'm trying to think of another statement. Murderer implies
You said somebody was like a if you called a baby a murderer,
people would be like that baby can't form an intent. So that
doesn't make sense. If you wanted to say that int intentionality
is implied, I think Hassan would agree. Then you can't apply
that to babies,
Settler implies an intentionality. I think the act of settling
implies intentionality.
I'm not sure that being a settler any more than being an immigrant,
right?
You can be a baby immigrant, can't you?
Or can are you saying babies can't be
is intentful. Babies can't be immigrants. A >> separate
thing to immigrate is to
have an intentionality. I think the term immigrant or the term
settler can refer also to um
>> That's a good way to handle it, right? That you would
be an immigrant if you came without the intent to immigrate to
the country. People would still consider you an immigrant, but
that the to immigrate would require intentionality
to decise to decide to immigrate, right?
Yeah. Okay. Beneath the, you know, age of um reason. Okay. So,
>> that guy's a DJ. He comes in here sometimes and then
he's like, "Destiny's the best." And then he leaves. >> Yeah.
I don't think there's anything I don't think there's anything
absurd about just the term settler being applied to babies any
more than, you know, an immigrant baby. A baby of an immigrant
baby would say.
And so
the negative
statements here
is in a misstatement of law which I'm granting for the purpose
of this
But crucially what's not happening
is he's not morally justifying
the of babies and everyone agrees with that right he's not morally
justifying
the babies. Well no unemployment means that you're I think the
technical definition of unemployed.
I do think they're unemployed babies. I think babies are all
unemployed, right?
>> Pisco, this is it's like it's like saying they're te
technically they're unemployed babies. >> Can we just examine
this guy? Fresh paycheck 7777.
>> I mean, that is technically true. Yeah. This guy's trying
to say that obviously if you're going to count unemployed babies
or have lengthy conversations about unemployed babies that means
you're being disingenuous about what employment, what unemployment
is. Is it a coherent? >> But it's like not I'd say unemployed
isn't a valuable qualifier to add on to baby. But baby settler
or baby immigrant, those might be important. Those might be I
don't know like those could be useful. Those aren't necessarily
worthless the same way like an unemployed baby is worthless to
talk >> Statement to say babies are unemployed. Is that
does that statement make sense? And is it correct? >> Yeah.
There's just no context where that adds value to any >> only
one person I'm looking at right now is fresh paychecks. Now you
could be taking the definition of unemployment. I'm I don't know
if I need more caffeine, man. I need >> employment, which
means you're actively looking for jobs. But then that's just
a different definition.
>> He's absolutely ethically justifying violence against
babies. All right, let's let's take a look. >> Is he ethically
justifying violence against babies? Where is that? >> If
you agree with that, I mean, that's almost a circular question,
right? It might even be moral if you agree with that, which is
with the actions.
You understand that? And then he says, I don't agree with it.
I don't think it's reasonable. I think it will eviscerate the
um Palestinian people. And I take what something is moral is
something that someone ought to do, right? what you ought do
and he's saying you ought not do that. So I I view that his statement
there is saying we ought not kill the babies. >> Uh I think
I think Pisco unless I'm misunderstanding I think Pisco must
have
and I think Hassan was doing a differentiation between believing
that all Israelis are settlers versus just people in the illegal
occupied areas are
I think I think Pisco misunderstood that part where he says,
"Oh, it's really unproductive or it's really bad." And I totally
disagree with saying all Israelis are settlers. I think that's
what's happening here.
It means something different when you use the word unemployed
to intuition pumps something about I don't even know what that
means. Intuition pumps something about the baby. It means something
different when you use the word unemployment to intuition pumps
something about the baby. I I don't even know what you're saying
there. It's clear. What do you think he means by baby settler?
Settlers of babies. Does anyone doubt that when he says baby
settler, he means babies of settlers? What do you think he means
other than that? If there's something other than babies of settlers
that you think he means by baby settlers, tell me what it is.
A baby who has settled. Isn't it clear and obvious? And I'm just
being mean like totally. Isn't it clear and >> Babies running
triple expansion tech these days. Very very
what he's talking about are the children of settlers. Baby settler.
Children of a settler. Even Grant that in order to be a settler
you have to have intentionality. All right. Grant it. Isn't it
obvious that in this context that he's saying it's the children
of settlers? It means babies are fair targets for Hamas.
Okay. From which perspective? From an ethical perspective or
from a legal >> Yeah, obviously. [laughter] Obviously.
Okay.
It seems pretty clear to me and I would hope a lot of other people
that
in this case he's dodging the moral question entirely. This is
probably almost impossible to to conclude based on what's been
said so far that he could say it's morally justified to kill
babies,
right? You could maybe say he's saying it's legally justified
to kill babies and you could get into an argument or a conversation
with him about why or why not. That is fine,
What he means by that, what he thinks about that. I guarantee
you Hassan has to understand
you you would imagine if Hassan's hide hiding his power level
he would have to
well obviously killing babies is wrong right you would think
I think yeah
here I'll speed it up again >> both in virtue of what we
think that's because I just heard saying he thinks it's something
we ought not to do I think he's complaining to do no I think
he's speifically not to do right doesn't he not do look at it
so you said that those bank are funding are you are you familiar
with the international surrounding the the judges he says not
the Bible forms of violence towards first but he brings it up
in the context of selfing legally right that's what he told me
that he want to be killed I'm not to me okay I don't put any
suffering
the reason why you have to exist in the west bank and behaving
in a manner that they behave >> where does this happen
through moral and different things it could be a highly moral
thing is because Palestinians boundary radical >> wow can
you name a case where that's happen this is a matter of law as
a matter of law that seems clear you saying law there and maybe
even if you agree this matter of morality this I take this to
not right if you perhaps at best with this policy but if you
distance in other words he's saying it's not necessary that you
if you believe it's legal that you believe it's good I think
that's clear that there's a distinction between those two saying
maybe it's moral if you agree with this a little ambiguous
maybe you could say if you agree with this is reference to a
law existing
I doubt it though >> I think I think Pisco co messed up
this >> He's saying it's a matter of law
on the law. >> So I take this to be this policy >> or
this action or this statement that we just heard. >> But
either way, it's clear there's a separation between lawying.
>> I do feel like I'm going to have to go grab the full
thing myself. >> I know the question asked wasn't that's
the weasel. That's the dodge. No, I totally agree with that.
But is there anything unreasonable about what I just said in
the following discreet? This is the only thing I'm looking at
right now that here pan statement clearly delineates between
legal and moral and does not imply that they're are co-extensive.
Maybe they result the same result but that they're different
inquiries. Everyone here must recognize that. Right? There's
no reasonable way to interpret this statement that doesn't recognize
that truth. Is he not saying that if you agree with this law
then it may be considered to be moral? That is one way to interpret
it. But even then, right, it's saying you you need not necessarily
agree with the law and in which case there's a separation still,
right? Even if you read it that way, which I wouldn't actually
not what I'm asking, right? So people, if you're too triggered
right now, I want you to leave. I want you to leave if you're
too >> In what universe is a baby a legal target? I don't
know.
Who gets arrested when a Palestinian baby's on the strike? Who
gets arrested?
Can I ask that? Hello. Is this thing on?
Lots of Palestinian babies got killed in after October 7th in
that whole
Hello. Doesn't seem like any of those people. Who's arrested
for that? Were people arrested for that?
Well, it seems like probably there's just no mechanism to hold
these people legally responsible, right? >> Right. Because
Darude Boy
is too triggered. Now, he's opining on whether he's correct about
what the law says. That's not the question I asked. Okay? And
if you're too triggered, you need to leave. You just need to
leave. All right? There's a very narrow thing here, which is,
is it the case in this clip in context that there is a separation
in Hassan's mind between law and ethics?
And if your the only thing I want to know is if your answer is
no to that in virtue of what is it no? And if you're too triggered
and you want to ask like irrelevant stuff,
then you should probably leave. He's been paused for a while
now.
I just want to see this last part. I might I might keep listening
for a little bit and possibly
possibly play some rivals for a little bit. We'll see. I'm pretty
tired though.
>> Well, I think we'll see I'm rivals >> right now.
Maybe >> what I'm not granting is that he has said that
it's moral to kill settler
That's what I'm not granting cuz I haven't heard that and that's
what it was sold to me as. I already explained what makes me
think that there's a difference, a distinction there that he's
playing there. And it's just the >> can can there exist
baby super chat? >> The plain words of what he says here,
If they're too triggered by this, like honestly, really just
>> calm down, take a breath, and listen to the words
>> has to exist in the West Bank and behave in the oppressive
manner that they behave is because Palestinians, and this is
going to sound very radical and possibly very violent, but this
is a matter of law and >> a matter of law. Even if you
agree with this a matter of morality >> and maybe even
if you agree with this this ambiguous grant this ambiguous
>> a matter of morality the maybe a matter of morality
sounds that in Hassan's mind the legal issue is settled the moral
issue is not settled they're not necessarily coexensive
is there any better way to interpret that statement in context
not triggered I'll grant you he said he didn't say it was more
babies where is it legal to okay right so so understand that
I I think that that's probably true that it's um not legal to
target a baby your question implying that but understand the
huge different moral implication in the following two scenarios.
Hassan thought it was legal to kill baby settlers and Hassan
wants settler babies to be right
cuz I'll give you the following example. Connor points thought
it was good that Alex Freddy was shot versus counterpoints thought
it was legal to kill Alex Freddy in that context. It was justified
use of force. Don't we see a massive gulf between those two statements?
a massive gulf.
And what this was sold to me as
was Hassan Per justifies
the babies equivocation yet again between legal justification
and moral
I have plenty of condemnation for Hassan based on this clip and
that is the weaselness not answering questions irrelevant tangents
on an issue where your interlocator has conceded the
to me it's the same
um if it were the
why would he be speaking this way I do wonder why he would be
speaking this way precisely if it were the same you know >> um
horrible statements on the pro-Israel side I think it's disgusting
not to acknowledge the um these horrible statements on the other
side plenty that is condemnable what it's not and what it actually
claim >> I like I agree with him I kind of want to get
to the next part because I want to watch this and then I want
to I want to play some rivals man come on man >> son justified
babies if I said it like
I would get called out on it and I would be wrong and I look
like a idiot and so I'm glad I like looked into this so now I
know the claim the claim is Hassan at this point in time legally
justified
seller babies and that has a very different implication. >> Well,
actually, >> you're straw man. >> Yeah, he said it's
legally justified. Sorry, I was going to say I think he
might be leaving something open to say like disagrees with that
law like or disagrees with the interpretation of the law. Possibly.
>> Who am I strawmaning?
>> Who am I straw maning? By justified, do you mean ethically
justify or or legally justify? Purple monkey dishwasher 9818.
I justify there. Do you mean ethically or legally justify? Well,
no. After this, he says it shouldn't happen. I take evil to mean
that which we must not
Right? Like I just take like something is good in virtue of we
ought do it and something is bad and we ought not do it both.
Okay. In virtue of I grant that he's legally justifying it here.
In virtue of what is he morally justifying it? No, I'm not saying
that there's a logical difference. I'm saying what in virtue
of what? What is the evidence that he morally supports babies
here? What's the evidence of that? That he morally supports these
babies in Israel. Whoops. What's the evidence of that claim?
What is the best evidence that Hassan morally supports
babies? I would agree this. I think he's legally justifying in
the context of sweeping for the people who think it is morally
justified. Um I think that he's definitely trying to downplay
their position. So I think they do believe it's morally justified
100%. Um and that is is its own bad thing, but I just don't think
that it's him ethically justifying it. The entirety of the podcast
of this podcast. >> I know. I think this is um totally
reasonable takeians
uh have the the legal ground to violently seize. >> It's
a it's a dog whistle. You think he's signaling that he does want
these babies to be
>> back their own homes from the settlers? This is a reality
and that is precisely the reason why they have to exist under
endless occupation. >> You know what? And that's why I
say if it was settlers that would be a lot more understandable.
But let's not off youcape. Okay, I understand what you're saying.
But this dude just called babies >> No, I understand. And
there are baby settlers. And just to be one trillion% clear here,
Ethan is suggesting that he might even agree that violence is
justified against Israeli settlers. I don't think he's saying
that about babies. Ethan is, but um >> well there are >> but
that presumably under international law with respect to civilians
would still be unjustified, right? >> Settlers as well.
There are babies in the settlements, >> but the babies
they killed weren't they were not. >> I know. Okay. So,
let's now we establish that. No, no, hold on. Now that we establish
that, >> the the other school of >> Yeah. I mean,
this is I think amazing that these same people can easily grasp
justification related to collateral damage and strikes, then
have this performative outrage. Yeah, I think I I think that's
what we're seeing in the chat is perform at 100%.